greetings from podcast Ville the Church
of what's happened now is brought to you
by on it
listen when it comes to supplement on it
is the [ __ ] choice I make in this
damn en go to on it right now and look
at this six week it's caught on it six
it's a six week figuration that you do
at home
[ __ ] body workout you're doing right
at your house six weeks to a better body
go to Anna comrade now press in church
boom and get that ten percent off on
this package number two I've been
telling this for months I got my Fuji
Gionta language it's who I feel good I
did good
I got submitted like eighteen times
that's not the point nobody ripped my
[ __ ] D why cuz I got a Fuji G and Fuji
mats and Fuji [ __ ] there I lived with
[ __ ] Fuji Fuji [ __ ] rash guard
listen go to Fuji Sports that time right
now I'm pressing charge
boom and get ten percent off your order
from Fuji or hot beside it what I'm
asking you for [ __ ] much you gotta
buy the gear anyway [ __ ] it might
as well pressing Church boom and give us
some credit here to [ __ ] Wednesday
morning grab your [ __ ] and salute the
flag [ __ ] it only gets better for me it
kick this [ __ ] meal leak what were
you doing the first time you heard how
early the first time you heard this
jessimae just give me an estimation
about seventeen what did you do
immediately uh grabbed my vibrator no I
I just I felt it I don't know it just
felt like I think was the first time I
realized oh everything else I've been
listening to before this was complete
[ __ ] like you can't go from new you can
go from New Kids on the Block to [ __ ]
Led Zeppelin like who put this out for
your brother a boyfriend I had friends a
tree musicians in Syracuse my uncle was
musician he had a band it was a disco
band but all those guys played that for
the gig but they all loved
Zeppelin and you know just like real
rock and roll and so I just I would ride
in cars with them and just be smoking
and drinking weed and listening to this
music yeah first time I heard this album
must have been 12 and I was scared Led
Zeppelin at that time you were scared of
it 11 12 I was still a Catholic
I still believed in God these people
have long hair and mustache ya know when
they did drugs I'm like I pay my mom did
drugs and [ __ ] but this was different
these guys were animals they were
animals like there was just white [ __ ]
animals and I was not tolerating it at
all so I didn't like affect you like you
wanted to like I like black music at the
time yeah like Spanish music like I
really like Spanish music and I like
black music WBLS type [ __ ] yeah finally
breaking into music like rock I was into
pop music like whatever was on WABC I
listened to it what was your pop my pop
was out John yeah don't go breaking my
heart oh my god twelve years old when I
was 12
well I got thrown out of Sacred Heart
School for Boys I went to McKinley in
the sixth grade in McKinley with the
public school public school in North
Bergen what'd you do to get thrown out I
beat the [ __ ] out of none that look a
nut on fire Jackie
me and four other characters I find it
really strange [ __ ] crazy you
couldn't stand Led Zepplin like their
music is literally it sounds like a nun
being set on fire well this whole
[ __ ] thing was I was into the whole
Catholicism thing I had heard rumors of
Devils [ __ ] like that was Led Zeppelin
that just wasn't me man you know but do
my Catholicism and my Santeria roots
right but then my Santeria cube root I'm
not listening to those up with death on
the other side it was on the other sides
of me so I just refused so I was down
John but you know if you didn't know he
was a [ __ ] in the sixth grade
I'm gonna check yourself you know when
you first saw Bernie Taupin the guy who
wrote a little music for me yeah yeah
like you know it was Philadelphia
freedom it was goodbye yellow brick road
god it was the heart and soul of Elton
John yeah I was like him it was it was
brilliant it was brilliant
Rocketman yeah that [ __ ] that they did
on that [ __ ] little genie yeah what's
the one they sang on almost famous when
they're on the bus tiny dancer Jesus
call that [ __ ] I grew up her Elton John
was
one of those every [ __ ] it seemed
like every 90 days was him being gay a
thing then no nobody knew anything
nobody knew nobody wanted to know it was
Liberace there was like six people if
you didn't know they were gay there was
something wrong with you but you over it
was so like Liberace for exam right you
don't say no like no like everybody main
believe I live around you numerology
he was something I don't know but I know
the barrage he's up to something
mm-hm he was only original Harvey
Weinstein's he was just doing it the
young boy was he was you know when the
movie came out I was a little disturbing
on HBO
that was the movie was disturbing
imagine a reality the reality of it has
to be even more disturbing movies
usually it's it's watered down and I
ain't mad at Harvey talking a little
young confused guys it's a suck on this
dick showing up with a wig Big Pimpin
suck his dick Marvin dressed as Liberace
I would be like a bad yeah I'm like you
added some flare to your deviance you
see how much money Liberace yeah you
know it's like people like that they're
so creative they don't know how to
handle the money like they start buying
like gold-plated toilet holders so what
are you doing you're like rapper rich
what are you doing everything was gold
famine must still be a kid like 19 maybe
18 I'm working for an electrician in
Aspen and I was installing electric
towel warmers but people just you should
have seen these bathrooms I was
installing this was already 1983 I need
it from my house now those 1983 you
should've seen yourself the size of the
bathroom was honest honest the size of
my living room and kitchen and where was
this like was just in New York Colorado
Colorado I mean there's a small yacht in
the mountains that's wealth right above
like maroon bells and [ __ ] yeah that's
what I call my tips we do a little
[ __ ] house anything there like there
was two houses and we planted duh I'd
never forget it was December 18th like
the summer
[ __ ] no why do you guys lose at winter
time it had to be December 20 December
22nd Christmas maybe [ __ ] three and
you couldn't see your hands toward the
snowflakes was so big and me and this
guy Greg the Jaeger the neighborhood
hopefully was Jaeger Electric and Aspen
Colorado that's how good my [ __ ]
memory your memory is really impressive
especially for the amount of edibles
[ __ ] Jaeger I I was working with
Aspen electric and things were starting
to blow up up there and I put a beat on
the guy up there and he disappeared
right like there was a guy that
disappeared this movie just took a turn
what that was
yeah strap that oh it wasn't those
lights of a company I may be 18 a
[ __ ] night oh my god I'm living
around all these yokels in Aspen
Colorado
I can't imagine you in Colorado Oh time
criminal but I'm watered down to an
electrician I'm an electricians help
from making maybe maybe nine an hour oh
and then I would wash dishes two nights
a week and I would steal everything that
was a staple down at that place from the
shrimp bags with french fries probably
can rob the waitresses I didn't give a
[ __ ] the coke dealer was the chef so I
he was cooked when I run to his house
and robbed him and go back and wash
dishes like nothing happened you would
not leave your job and run to his house
yes I would towards the end I was how is
that [ __ ] the end you're 18 were you
feeding sweetness excuse me refeed in an
addiction at that time oh you rob was
three more the addiction of just like a
house being a piece of [ __ ] yeah it was
what might make my dick hard
mm-hmm was if I found that just my
Peluso was just come back yeah she's
going down yeah and I would [ __ ] with
you first a little bit yeah mentally I'd
break into your house and steal like 100
uh a wallet yeah and I'd be like who the
[ __ ] mental warfare then I going to you
how to coke and take an 8-ball out my
mind would be a organic green tea it'd
be really boring
the [ __ ] is going on right is there a
ghost and it was just that type of [ __ ]
I was just going crazy I was working for
this country company Aspen electric and
we were doing this taxi cab place where
it's like that 12 bays right
six of them were wash them like service
and then the other three I don't know
what the [ __ ] they were and we had
install like those long light bulbs
mm-hmm I figure out what they called and
we had yeah plug and we were there for
like three months
and they kept switching guys and finally
hit me with this dude that was just the
deck like nobody got long in the company
nobody like they cabbie he got the
arguments of people it was a no at all
he was maybe if I was 18 and 19 he was
maybe 40 ish 38 yeah 35 is just a real
[ __ ] price right and he probably was
more of a prick because you were younger
I used to [ __ ] with New York mm-hmm
[ __ ] Yankee [ __ ]
Oh rash [ __ ] well that sets I'm talking
from a few guys like at lunchtime some
guys were there with us they were
working around the corner or something
and they were we were there someone they
left an hour later he just came out of
nowhere with a knife and put it to my
neck one of those cut in the box cut off
is that coach ever disrespect me and get
it from these [ __ ] people and he had
me Jessica it was nothing to do I was
standing on pipes to boot so I had so
dry had no footage yeah and he had me I
had this [ __ ] just on street
value alone I had him just on what I
knew but I couldn't make a move I
couldn't even reach him or a wallet and
reach for pipe nothing I was on pipes so
I said you're the man and I let him go
when I thought about my told this guy
was shooting with on Sundays they goes
listen you're gonna go back to Jersey to
live that dumb and shoot him on a Django
yeah he was practice on him so like two
weeks I went down and I know all his
moves and I worked at the guy and then I
would say oh what are you doing tonight
was born a birthday just telling you
everything but I lived 20 miles from it
yeah so I had a stalk him flight
oh my god now watch a bar he went and
then I piped one line I piped them with
a I got him with a hanger and one of
those you know those sticks that Bruce
Lee use them into the Dragons nunchucks
the one just one along the long one oh
yeah like a night watcher slick it's
where did you get that Walmart what's
with the question though at your local
Dick's Sporting no no you couldn't get
nothing because they trade you got to
assume they could trace everything right
a trunk he got it from a trunk Lee the
same place that slice of salami was at
your feet that's right you gonna have
you get a hanger you open the hangar
right take electrical tape and you
flatten out that hangar you make a
handle you make like a 12-inch
handle is everybody listening then you
take that hanger and if I whipped you
with that hanger at night you won't know
what's going on for the first two
minutes it sounds like you would also
well you just get what you're seeing is
this and you're gone and you can't see
you know pop in the face first yeah it's
hard so I got the guy of a Saturday and
that Monday he didn't go to work I'm
sitting at work I don't like hours even
my comings and sake you know as I left
him there yeah well for his life did he
see you no I had a mask on okay hit him
in the face with a hanger-on had
everything he'd wanna see me this is my
first step he didn't want to see me so I
beat him up a little bit and just ran
away
yeah I threw the mask away in the jacket
as I was driving and all this [ __ ] I
went back to Fred's I went to my house
this low mass that Monday I went back to
work and I loved it happened oh my god
he didn't call entire whatever he didn't
come in that was it nobody said none
Tuesday no he said not Wednesday at the
breakfast or lunch at that when you come
in the guy would always come on okay
today's lineup Lee you're going with
jessimae over to the house up and Aspen
you're finishing up the rear ooh [ __ ]
how come I gotta go get the [ __ ] out
Joey you're going with Stan you're going
up the Snowmass Village to finish up the
apartments up there I think I would give
you all this he would come out but on
the third day he's like what is [ __ ]
whatever
the guy's name was theirs where is he
anybody here from it watch you pass by
his house on the way down forehead job
and see what's going on maybe sick maybe
his phone's broken there maybe nobody's
heard from Emmys deadness condo I listen
then gone oh [ __ ] man he got beat up and
that I could wait to come back at 4:30
to find that would happen we got to like
have 10 to 5 and over time but still
suck because that my heart was beating
there the guys drink coffee knowing man
that's the weirdest thing yeah we went
to his house he moved he moves yo that's
a good beat and you beat someone so bad
they [ __ ] move [ __ ] big company left
I think they don't even want to tell on
you they move that's powerful I think
I'd probably do the same thing
[ __ ] you got beat up in the in the D
word always me yeah you don't wait you
wouldn't hurt anybody in the first place
I hope not not enough to get beat up in
the dark not even emotionally I don't
know maybe but that's Jesus Christ
you're not worried that he's listen to
this okay say yeah yeah people still
have rights
yeah it's to prove on their have you
seen them fight he's - the proof what
year it is what month it was these times
they come up with a lot of [ __ ] so yeah
I feel like a month of sitting there
waiting what is this guy gonna come back
and get me you thought that I really
thought that man the job started dying
down and one day I met this guy outside
of like [ __ ] a supermarket in the
admin a lot of electrical saying I left
I'm like a man like oh hey my name is
Joey I'm gonna let you go hop but do you
mean anything he knows that right now
but it is my car keep in touch him
there's a type of experience you have I
can tell them you're like I'm really
good with hangars and then I call them
like twice and the second time because
you could start tomorrow full time so
that's why I remember hanging that I'll
never forget hang in that [ __ ] I
forget what you call it now I was 30
[ __ ] years at all people there's my
first piece electricity to a
neighborhood like the first night first
two is that it's the first wire that
gets the whole hood and we do the
the post you pull a post and then you
put like a boy aboard aboard aboard we
live a [ __ ]
I'll never forget that I'm late bro we
gotta go home as the snow was coming
down we can't go home
this has to be done today me and him
went in this [ __ ] blizzard cars were
doing [ __ ] 60 past us we were like 20
feet from the road and the cars were
sliding off the road on my toe
let me get [ __ ] kill they're $9 an
hour the light bucks now maybe at the
time maybe 10 who the [ __ ] you're like I
just want to go to people's houses and
steal their [ __ ] why am I in this no but
that was my cover jessimae see if you
see the house I lived in such a small
community at the time if I didn't go to
work they would peg me for the thief
right so in my world I was always
working just to keep good face even when
I had those two weeks off over the
holidays yeah I would shovel snow for
[ __ ] 15 in our cash it was that like
a cocaine Aoife nism are you like
actually son with shovel snow outside
but I'd be case the joints I looked at
what time jessimae leaves what time she
comes back who she leaves with because
of all the condos were together it was
like see it was like ABCD or we were all
together was I forget what they're great
departments were called smoker your bar
hello
yeah so they were all together so I'd be
out there shall we
I'd see you leave I'd Celia leave you
take a little time stamp in your mind
sure that's how professionals do it and
then I had my room where that I was an
engineer on paper so all the [ __ ]
paper College world listen let's say you
want this I'll tell you went to school
for four years and you got all hate
buses
you're supposed to graduate in June and
then [ __ ] January you get into a
fight when they do it's not six or a
month you're not graduating you're not
graduate now he came back home his
brother had graduated from Brown he was
at the f was Kabbalist this whole family
was genius the older brother was at
Brown going to school with Jackie
Kennedy's son we were talking about the
cat before yeah I still remember
visiting him
what debt and jackieo was on campus
they'd be yelling [ __ ] they were crazy
there Jackie if they were only alive
today and realize what real [ __ ] are
[ __ ] crazy
who are this for my gun so that the one
brother went to Yale the other brother
went to listen to this the other brother
went to the Air Force Academy and got
thrown out of this senior year and he
was a genius why do you get thrown out
forget into a fistfight
I mean I mean and then the other brother
was a great mechanic in grammar school
you know those kids that live next door
they were fixing alarm clocks I didn't
have this Walker and he was living out
in San Diego but the other brothers very
interesting was I telling you this Lee
the other day like a little off the
other brother no the other brothers a
janitor at the World Trade Center that
seems like a very smart job the first
time they bombed the building he was
drinking across the street before he's
an ally thank God first time to building
a bomb in 94 93 he was across the street
getting drunk on a Friday the second
time we got bombed he was down the shore
he called in sick because he was
hungover Wow sundae's alcoholism saved
his life ironically you never know what
it's gonna be
you never know if it's a DJ it can be a
[ __ ] sue column Inc or it can be
[ __ ] alcoholism something's gonna
save your life
jessimae Peluso where the [ __ ] you're
open you came in here with some white
dude that look like a mad scientist with
18 weeds he brought you so much weed
that was Travis [ __ ] a baguette we
had on earthquake weed yeah that's my
shot right here in there just we smoked
a bunch of it then we save like the half
ounce yeah you guys sit still in there
get moldy nice oh good there's an
earthquake melee go straight this
[ __ ] hide under the couch and
smoke each other out that's it that's
you're gonna be fine you're gonna be
[ __ ] fine I'll please we'll be in the
hey [ __ ] baby this is a great place
to hotbox
cuz you got like professional lighting
and I feel like being high with that is
really anxious special you said you're
gonna go police
so you called me you wanted me to your
grand opening it was a it was our soft
opening for friends so here I figured
you were rockin and rollin and I see no
still in the road
not as much I've just been writing a lot
writing a bunch of [ __ ] and working on
you know movies and stuff I'm trying to
write a movie right now that seems like
I don't know if that's a good idea
because I feel like it takes 17 years
for the movie to even be shot
I've never ever embarked on that what
happens if you don't worry I would go
crazy okay then
yeah that's your answer yeah exactly you
know today I woke up saw his [ __ ] wanna
kick boxing it's Monday yeah you can't
spell is [ __ ]
and I went today I have a chance to and
my daughter's home she graduated on
[ __ ] Friday so there's no school this
week so tomorrow or Thursday were all in
Disneyland so [ __ ] what a dream for a
little girl believe this holy hell
that's gonna cost you an arm and a leg
have fun with that you better bring a
backpack I'd even ask my wife you don't
want to go you better like bring a extra
hand
I just know it's gonna be a G oh please
a G is complementing that's are you
giving them at the door you're out
that's a hot dog puts you off [ __ ]
crazy is that this economy today that a
family cannot go to Disneyland a [ __ ]
Laker game for less than you know $300 a
Yankee game it's just $50 to park
gas is $5 a gallon right now $50 what
o'clock and then to drive there what
does the American family do today
they suck dick to survive two kids and
two
it's insane they can't do yeah well you
can't well the reality is 600 a plane
ticket I mean your bosses you can't do
Dickinson time together you're working
you're working the whole [ __ ] time to
go and do [ __ ] for three hours cuz the
rest of the time you got to work to be
able to pay for everything it's [ __ ]
crazy that's what I've been doing I just
been working working you know sometimes
you work and people don't see you but
you're doing a lot of [ __ ] like a cop
I've been like a cockroach lately just
like working on things that are gonna be
have a little bit more longevity I've
been doing sets and stuff and still on
the road I told you I wasn't I'm gonna
be in Pasadena on Saturday but yeah I
just been trying to like crate [ __ ] that
I actually care about my dad recently
got diagnosed with Alzheimer's so that's
that totally changed my perspective on
everything like when real [ __ ] happens I
mean you know your whole life has been
[ __ ] turmoil and just dealing and
surviving but like when someone you love
has that sort of thing happened to you
you start to shake up the [ __ ] that
you're going through and see what's
really important then you shed all the
fat and they start focusing on real
stuff so that's what I've been doing I
just been like pivoting my career in my
life getting it in a direction where I'm
working on [ __ ] that actually will
sustain me emotionally not doing
anything for money so crazy well that
first moved here the first five years I
was at the store every night yeah and in
my mind they're fighting to see you you
were like what [ __ ] are you my god I was
either at the improbable I was what I
should say is I would always end up at
the store yeah I'd be at the improv I'll
eat all the Mexican rooms very three or
four times a year in the old days I
would go to the Laugh Factory but I was
everywhere else yeah well you don't see
people are you go what the [ __ ] is up
with that yeah where the [ __ ] are they
well guess what now I understand that
yeah now I understand that I'm gonna
have to go listen if I do a podcast two
nights a week if I go stage two nights a
week that's four yeah if I see my wife
one night and if you know like you try
to do two spot
right see don't force box yep so when
you're in town you're doing five to six
pots a week yep time you've got it
you've got to have some sort of [ __ ]
balance there's if someone said to me
recently my agent actually said to me
there's no such thing as work/life
balance there is if you really want to
be successful balance is the only thing
that's gonna get you there let's stop
right now because you're gonna get my
blood pressure I know
let me explain one thing yeah everything
I say you're like what I love my agents
daily I love my managers daily but we
live in a time when they're not too good
at their job it's really crazy I like my
agents a lot and my managers and I like
them but they're not good shits changing
so fast also like in their defense
they're competing with like you know
drunk people who have successful YouTube
pages that are you know I don't know
making pasta fazool I don't know what
they're doing but there's the the level
of celebrity has changed like who's the
celebrity now has changed and where
they're focused where their focus is is
also changed there's like we're you know
we're competing with YouTube celebrities
and instakill so I feel like
everything's diluted now and they're in
a panic cuz they don't know how to
market these people and they're trying
to market these other people who are new
in the industry and put them on the
[ __ ] road and then everybody else
sort of it's hard to balance all of
their other clients like but you're
right it is it's a it's a weird time to
be an entertainer it's a weird time
first off I'm not competing with nobody
because I'm not trying to be famous and
I'm not trying to be on TV no more yeah
yeah I'm just trying to exist for five
more [ __ ] news
yeah and then like there's a ranch
somewhere that's waiting for uncle Joey
a ranch in the sky are like legit place
the link Omaha retire there
some oh there's a ranch with my [ __ ]
wallet oh are you really gonna shave I
have no idea I better get invited it's
holding on right now I hope you get
horses you know or El Paso at the very
least you know I it's sad
what's up listen I knew well I did my
first movie that the life of a celebrity
was not the life I like though that's
how I feel I feel that I don't like the
way people treat them I don't like how
they treat people I don't like what they
do to people how they act on the sets it
was never for me
yeah always a job for me mm-hmm what I
found that insurance and it was just a
job yeah you know I did some great
projects I really and I learned a lot I
learned a lot about the business there's
so much more than what people see so
much more so much involved and just so
much creating oh and you uh he finally I
took all the [ __ ] junk I had already
you know I'm here since I was 20 years
so I've been here since I was 55 35 but
wait so when I said there's no such
thing as work-life balance what did that
well hi what is your response to that as
somebody who's been through this whole
cooking industry my response is this
okay they have a job to do and you have
a job to do their job is to put you on
the road every week from Wednesday to
Sunday which I'm mad at that
yeah think about us which it that was my
job depend partly on Wednesday the
Sunday this muhfucka be rolling and
pepperoni
this [ __ ] would be out every
week I talked him into a different town
buy food it's a little cup they're
getting pimped out every weekend a
garbage play in Philly we gain yeah I'm
just sending up two places
one hundred then I'll put the poem
inside the to a fat camp have CA a pay
for it and then put them back out there
again let him bust his [ __ ] had some
blood they don't care no you know
there's no science to it home law do
this to do this yeah strategy there's
nothing I you know listen I know exactly
what I want I know what I don't want
mm-hmm I love working on TV but it's
gotta be a certain way and I'm not
working on the film there's gotta be a
certain way and I'm nobody to the man
that way yeah it's never gonna happen
yeah it's no but there's that but that
there's beauty and then that's beauty
there's freedom and that's it that's it
I just want to keep doing this to Lee
comes to me and says he doesn't want to
do the podcast moment until literally
his eyes cannot open ever again I think
I was gonna happen when Lee his face is
just gonna become like permanently
stoned and you're only gonna be able to
pierce or like a millimeter slit in your
eyes look like right now do you think
I'll get disability for them I hope so I
hope you die nothing I am like don't one
of the appealing things no thank you my
cookie you don't want wait you know what
my natural cookie no again it is
appealing to be able to do what you guys
do from anywhere like it's you if you
really didn't want to you didn't hey
you'll have to live in LA yeah that's
true and that you know that's the ideal
like podcasting that's my podcasting so
great and that's why stand-up is so
great you can just travel and you meet
people and you have these places that
you've never gone to before and I like
that part of it and and I'm just I'm
learning and embracing being more
independent and selective about what I
do and so I took time to really think
about what the [ __ ] I want to do and
what the [ __ ] I want to do is I want to
write a movie I want to talk about
what's going on my dad and share that
[ __ ] I want to bleed a little onstage I
want it to like you know I'm all cool
I'm cool the dick joke I love a dick
joke but it's got to come from my heart
is there a Doberman barking someplace
well might be did my edible okay kid
[ __ ] Rottweiler on the other side
well what does name measure success is
going from area the area and staying
entertained mm-hmm okay
well my philosophy on this was no matter
what I was always gonna have 320 hour or
a week job yeah do you say yeah because
one weekend for the other would count to
the other mm-hm
you would have two jobs Monday to Friday
and then a job Sall veins yeah and every
job had a purpose sadly and Sunday's job
wasn't really strenuous I didn't really
get rich but it saved me eight hundred
yeah a weekend because I'm not doing
stupid [ __ ] on the weekends right if
you're single you could live that life
yeah yeah yeah yeah so the agents job is
to book you and your job is to have a
life yes your job is to go listen yeah
I'm going on every week this is what I
average a month I'm living like a pimp
mm-hmm and you become blind by that pimp
yes you do and next thing you know you
have a publicist you have all these
people taking money out of your copier
accoutrements you don't need you don't
need you don't need that make you
believe you need all that [ __ ] garbage
and it's such a it's like when you go
for a car they're like oh put the pro
package and you also gotta get the slaps
and you got them no then it's like you
don't need all those accessories well
the car get me from A to B don't put the
[ __ ] fancy [ __ ] on it no I can put my
own gas in the tank I feel bad when
people first get here
oh and they really put you to leave you
don't remember this no what is this do
you don't have an agent and it's the 13
agency manager good you don't need an
agent do this every casting director
looks at these you put six headshots up
you pay them 300 hours think I was the
director wants a person they press a
button and your picture comes up
what's that cost that cost you [ __ ]
300 a year
then the headshot to 400 and then again
and then the [ __ ] to put two
headshots down at the commercial place
is $50 a head shot the third one is free
thanks thanks so the first two of 50
bucks apiece and the third one is free
thanks thanks but you're really helping
my [ __ ] family out like everything's
a [ __ ] scared
so yeah you go out on commercial edition
but let me tell you what happens when
you're like for you for you people were
sitting there going you know what I
can't wait till I'm [ __ ] sag let me
lay an eye on you you little [ __ ] let
me pay what sag means sag means that
they take more money out of your pocket
without you knowing because first of all
it's 37,000 to get level one insurance
and it's 25,000 to get level two
insurance then after that your [ __ ] you
might as well listen you know how hard
it is to get to twenty-five and thirty
seven thousand dollars consistently on a
thousand dollar a job you hardly get
sleep as well pray that Harvey gets
acquittal yeah and you get back to
sucking jack yeah I know there's a bunch
of [ __ ] somewhere going [ __ ] Harvey's
not been no more that was my ticket I
was just working on a divorce to get out
there 23 with this good ass Bombay [ __ ]
and drop it on these white Jewish fools
and [ __ ] and start suing [ __ ]
I'm gonna meet to banner and [ __ ] yeah
are you kidding me or what yeah sorry
about that people they [ __ ] rape
every [ __ ] level B let me tell you
about say I'm outside work so you booked
your little first job you call home
daddy daddy mommy mommy I booked my
first job oh we're so proud of you
whether you come on TV oh my god it's a
new show on CW they bought 11 episodes
I'm on the 11th one I played
why you gonna live in two words you do
got a wine it yeah your liner - and then
you get boom and then you're happy and
then like two weeks later you book
another job and now it run right
commercial it's tremendous because the
agent calls you says oh my god Lee you
booked this job congratulations it pays
1350 you shoot June 14th and that's it
and all sudden you'll be sitting on
woofing you'll call your friends going I
made it I made it
sawsan you get this call beep and it's
three two three five four nine something
you're like who's this this must be like
[ __ ] some producer it wants to talk
to me the [ __ ]
anyway hello and they're like hi is this
house I'm like yeah this is Jose and oh
okay this is Mildred from Screen Actors
Guild Jose opposing political views
congratulations on this job you booked
yes yes congratulations thank you what
the bad news is this what there's no bad
news I gotta tell you it's all good news
the good news is you're spoiling Screen
Actors Guild nap
so what we need from you is to tell us
how we're gonna pay for this little
transaction you're sitting there going
what are you talking about I just booked
a job on land getting 1200 I get a check
in [ __ ] pen days I'm snorting I'm
[ __ ] that little waitress in the
store in the ass writing great I'm doing
great what are you talking about they're
like no to shoot that gentleman it's
gonna cost you what's it gonna cost me
it's gonna cost you fifteen hundred it
cost me twelve they asked me for twelve
on the phone right away 1250 how you
gonna pay for this cash charge what do
you want to do what are you talking
about the like we need about 1250 Bert
how'd you get it done that was then it's
20 it's like you sir it's like three
yeah it's twenty seven fifty and now
they finance
yep they were like oh sorry I'm like how
about I give you three and pay you when
I get the check another
EEE Mildred's like this angular word was
there it was 1250 and you better have it
the day I would you want stepping on
that set there's gonna be a do from sag
wait people don't realize there's union
jobs jobs so ok in order to work you
have to get into the Union from poor
your grandfather he lends you a thousand
Leland's you're five we don't got five
finally [ __ ] take a thousand from
Morrow for a small fee and you pay for
say now you get that job Haley back and
you got a few jobs and you pay Lee back
and you get a boom but everything is
hunky-dory so great you can't we set the
standard and then January 3rd Lee goes
through his mailbox and he sees his
letter from sag that looks like a check
dude it looks like a check I got they
even put it like that - looks like open
it up and it's dues like hey wait in the
check to write to them it takes like two
and a half points it's a sliding scale
it's like a sliding scale to want to
have points from what you made three
years what mm-hmm
then they hit you with that one and then
no wonder you know the doctor so much
[ __ ] I would be up there sometimes I
just gonna say how long a face on my
head will bang me out for 35 he's from
Chicago so we talk about food he
thousand I brings the [ __ ] food back
with Chicago and stuff oh I got a lazy
labia doc I make funny around all the
time so then they hit you back me again
then they you back with the washout for
the year yeah then you got you got the
end-of-the-year dues and this is the
only way and you have to get it get your
new card oh yeah you get that baby you
get this I just got mine - what does
that give you that gives you basically
remember remember right let me see what
it gives you it gives you access to
health care
[Laughter]
that card don't get you dead there was a
time you know that movie TV you go to a
time when it got you something let me
tell you something about that movie
theater and know that you like that they
redid a cinema the Cinemark the cinema
was in a fucked-up neighborhood they got
like that for all the [ __ ] it was not
Jitsu school around the corner and stuff
let me taste them about that place that
place held on they were the last place
that that card meant some where you got
a discount free ticket free pick see
this it's you don't get [ __ ] with it so
no you don't get nothing with it no more
that was the last of the benefits there
was a couple movie theaters in Hollywood
that let you go in for free and that
place I got a stack of those I got every
one of my this is nineteen nine years to
get hurt I read every year okay yeah it
cost money this don't you just don't
know you gotta pay your do you gotta pay
your sliding scale dues I just got my
little spires in 2000 yeah you see and
then you have your tumbleweed do you
have your dues every year - or do they
do it yeah they don't roll that into you
number since 1998 who the [ __ ] you think
you're dealing with you won't get your
card unless you pay so wait see if they
pay thousands every year plus the
percentage of what you make yes
oh you see without a way to get on sag
you want your dreams let you know right
now dreams are expensive and now I think
they want to what let's be correct one
they want we go this I don't think
they'll tell you online so Will Smith is
giving them three percent or whatever of
what he's making they they make so much
money like it's literally based off of
your earnings off your earnings so I
think it's like I give them one of the
half percent cuz I'm in the lower [ __ ]
- yeah my - mine too but I think the
more you make I think like Stallone it
will submit there's no way they're
paying for movie tickets their cards
must get them at least an in-and-out
burger I mean they must be getting the
milkshake
you think Stallone's not getting nothing
free oh yeah that means anything still
all these people I go to a movie do you
not gonna charge Stallone you what do
you think - still don't like do you
think it gets free [ __ ] all the time
those guys get free [ __ ] everywhere
right like my heart like oil changes
give Stallone a [ __ ] restaurant bill
if you owned a restaurant and Sylvester
Stallone came back I don't think I would
I would go over tell him that my boss
said thank you come again and that would
be my chance to shine I go out there and
shake this ham and say thank you for
coming to my restaurant do you mind
taking a picture cause you're like
you've had a long career who's somebody
you've met that you were in like
awestruck with or somebody like in the
industry who you wanted to meet you got
to me and it was like a pivotal moment
for you was there anybody like that like
anybody quote-unquote famous that you
looked up to as a kid or something that
you happen to cross paths with along the
career was there was a lot of people
like idea what creeps me out the most
about being here yeah the people that I
watched as a civilian that's a great way
to put it died bump into that that's
crazy like I saw the movie 29th Street
as a civilian right so all those people
in that movie from Vinny card out to
Anthony LaPaglia to to [ __ ] Paulie
from Paulie walnuts from Goodfellas all
those people I saw as a civilian right
but pre-clearance I want to see this
movie this check I want to go see I
don't know what I want to go say and
there's how Pisa is yeah talk me into
going to see a movie or splash with Tom
Hanks and Daryl Hannah
holy [ __ ] that was a great one boy who
played the brother but uh oh god what's
his [ __ ] Andy John King yeah John Candy
this on the opening scene it's a dude
from New York yep
he bring us some cherries Vinnie was
going on with the cherries delivery
he's delivery yeah the delivery trucks
he goes you know he had a full house I
had to repair we made a deal you better
deal my brother yeah he said he'd take
the cherries I always love to thank I
said wow what a [ __ ] great guy that
guy's for the New York that's the guy I
need to be boom I did a movie and he was
the guy that played the delicatessen no
put it on
see if you Vimeo so let me somebody
found it Raphael owes pizza that's the
name of the movie
the name of the tea of the short this
very interesting what happened here yeah
but let's see if it's on there Ralphie
yellows pizza maybe they changed the
name who the [ __ ] knows Raphael's pizza
yeah we did a sketch and the sketch got
picked up by HBO this is Wow it's what
your first things baby just post
somebody just posted it how old were you
this had a B I was still doing blow BB
or a B before blow after blow before
during blow that's what I learned
something so much deeper into your
psyche yeah this was 2006
maybe the holidays of 2006 they posted
it there was rumors did you finally I
don't think so no I can't find it
somebody posted it somebody found it and
posted it also you guys see how there's
more [ __ ] spelling Rafaela
it's bound like a Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtle yeah but capital R let's have a
capital no no no that's what like six
ELLs no these are more this what I deal
with all the time spelling championship
against a Chinese kid Chapel all right I
love that I have to make a sure about
something with the capital for the yeah
because nobody [ __ ] knows the
location [ __ ] I don't know [ __ ]
lowercase I know capital small that's in
big one your [ __ ] I did it small right
so RAF ruff-ruff yes ok e8 ll o
apostrophe s EA EA Rafi's ellos Pizza
Pizza I did that came up see ok what's
one pizza this way or the do you mean
right here ok the way I thought it
should be spelled same thing is it
Raphael O's friend
Vimeo right here yeah Romeo oh wait go
down here this one what's this one you
believe this I do believe I deal with
this young kid what here I'll look these
kids live on the [ __ ] computer is
this your actual computer oh [ __ ] scroll
this place scroll
oh yeah that one's too short for it to
be do you think they took it off with
Joey Diaz on that this is Vimeo correct
oh this is [ __ ] Google go to [ __ ]
Vimeo please just throw the wreck to
Vimeo talking about you see I got deal
with that's why I'm like this don't
worry my mother
no he's just talking to me no [ __ ]
Vimeo this is still Google I'm gonna be
I was on wrong look he spills the me
over me like Vimeo
Vimeo wouldn't know any nothing higher
than ego or dota [ __ ] we had video
Chaplin or hey yeah
Oh apostrophe s Quinta
Rafael of Pizza
nothing what the [ __ ] the confused robot
doesn't know who this Rafael had
replaced the two apps with a pH did you
know something I couldn't I can really
see that do you think they took it down
right do it again then I did the same
robot came up you should pull up all
your videos yeah see Joey Diaz videos
and now [ __ ] clearing up unbelievable
what I got a deal well this guy was the
splash oh [ __ ] I forgot overtime huh a
lot and all of a sudden I go up to this
[ __ ] pizza place up in uh in what do
you call that [ __ ] I go to this pizza
place in Calabasas at midnight dollars
shoot and there's that guy standing
there and I went up to him like oh my
god you're my favorite splash and he
goes what the [ __ ] are you talking about
and what that was 1983 he got I
consulted in a way the guy really yeah
and then we became friends he was really
cool me and him and I got him a role and
something they wanted me for something I
can't believe that audition tape
okay enemy Oh someone there's someone
found on YouTube yeah you told me to get
off of Google Google owns YouTube yeah
you're awful [ __ ] Google was not
gonna give it to you
each imagine go to Twitter where they
send TF Twitter watch this so this guy
told me long ago you found it yeah oh my
god say thank you
[ __ ] thank you you told me the wrong
time years old college educated spelling
right either by the way just saying good
that's why that's why I hire you 29 in
college educated
they'll teach us how to spell Italian
name that just sound louder please so
she could hear it oh my god would be the
salt on this floor holding me fault
wait I thought the me phone you guys are
so cute you're like a married couple
Joey you've dropped some elby's I saw a
little thumbnail of you you've dropped
some elby's I was gonna take away what's
going on that's come ah
it may be inappropriate for younger
viewers
I don't [ __ ] I eat on the bus just
because she is so nice Angelina let me
get up tonight you understand no goofy
look at the nose is clogged dog from the
blow this has been getting me a [ __ ]
slice
hey Joey how many times I gotta tell you
not to mention my sister well what the
[ __ ] you gonna do you [ __ ] you to make
them prick
Jesus hey Joey I love you bro like
family you're noticed but how many times
I gotta [ __ ] tell you not to mention
my sister
[Laughter]
shut the [ __ ] up [ __ ] [ __ ]
this is my boss you know how to bust my
balls newb all bhai
well you know I apologize okay is that
good number stop now get some [ __ ]
fool now bounce you [ __ ] [ __ ] the
drive-through
you see a big purple [ __ ] dancing around
with a clown and a [ __ ] lesbian bird
you want that food you don't come in
here there's a bill that we don't look
[ __ ] hamburgers here Sammy hey I'm
with my that's why good if I would Joey
you notice anything for you anything
hey don't go there you know I already
you wanna do your face it says where's
my pepper what was the audition process
like freely I found this is your face I
found this this was when you could
submit yourself mm-hmm knows what's like
backstage and those websites it was the
one that you're originally on I don't
want that yeah yeah yeah yeah I know
you're talking about has a option you
can submit 15 years ago the first year
shows would post in it yeah I got in
coal case that's great look at the first
year at cold case disco invasion uh so
yeah I was the disco guy I was that
Francine joy mineiro because it was on
there and this was on that that's why it
was it would be $70 a year to submit all
you wanted yeah or a dollar of
submission I took my chance I paid a
dollar of submission and that book okay
side Law and Order SVU that's crazy
I booked this I booked I probably bought
six or seven jobs would you get paid for
this one
do you remember it was a after a
low-budget pilot and after is a
subdivision of sag hundred dollars but I
made them pay me cash yeah you did
excuse you gangster because I'm gangster
I got show up you pay me and they'd let
me out of the oven so the coke dealer
was open til one
yeah you turn that cash right around the
economy back into the Navy yeah you're a
civilian so yeah I think like cold case
paid me scale the job that was kinky was
I got a job in Jamaica shooting the
movie and I should have known the movie
was king when I was a text at suggest
the cast was pure garbage and I went
down there and I they were sag and at
this time I had done a bunch of [ __ ]
yeah
so you just smell different rats yeah
like once you don't get that you know
the same real life I worked on Maria
always wear
overnight women's organic they overnight
you [ __ ] from New York every day no
you're not it you know what's that
course that's 995 a shot every day well
I didn't analyze that that was booked
out of New York they would send me
changes every day bags of them bags at
them at $10 apiece
you think any of those things had to do
with me they'd change that one of my
wines just the money they spent this is
such a waste just the money spent it's a
nickel a first-class historicity in the
back of the [ __ ] plane on the
frontier and they lost my luggage is
some [ __ ] it was [ __ ] crazy you know
just the money that they stay spend like
during The Longest Yard I remember one
time I asked Adam for something and the
one of the producers came over to me
said that's absurd we can't do it
and I found on that [ __ ] a week later
that they decided to hire some guy like
Monday neither they but they needed a
met Tuesday at 9:00 and they overnight
swarm from Minneapolis seeing the cost
$35,000 no so you couldn't wait for a
commercial flight and push that scene
back to 12
$35,000 oh yeah put him on a flight from
Minneapolis overnight one of those
[ __ ] oh I see write write write write
write 35 G's what's the with this guy
was so crucial to the movie I'd only
want to tell you was so embarrassing he
was so crucial to the movie because the
scene couldn't wait to what you gotta
[ __ ] tell him you couldn't fly the 6
a.m. you couldn't take the 6 a.m.
do you remember it was I forget what his
name was believed was a retired
quarterback Oh Jay Simpson no he was
retired like that wasn't any good well
he was a sweetheart of a guy he was a
[ __ ] Brett Favre no he was a [ __ ]
blow job Dennis Rodman no and Babe Ruth
I don't know it was [ __ ] crazy that
they fool man nice guy they flew in for
one scene he ends up staying like four
days and each night late the next
morning people are like dog the Jews am
Leslie he was lit to the [ __ ] kill
Sykes passed out that type of jury was
enjoying himself good guy you know he
was there and they the mornings day like
nothing happened yeah but uh
no that type of [ __ ] pisses you off you
know and just where you people want to
join sagashiteru red you don't like him
you do a Netflix job now you can't
really get a raise yeah because Netflix
don't give you a count no I don't they
don't let you know what they're gonna
chose what their algorithm is they don't
let you know the data nothing it's not
on there in but it's also kind of sneaky
that was taking a shower you know you
ever take a shower and you get weird
thoughts oh [ __ ] not sexual nothing no
your brain is just like I was thinking
about interview with Jennifer Aniston
when she was interviewed for was the
actress studio and she told a pretty
interesting story maybe it was it wasn't
Jenna it was Jennifer Aniston and she
told the story of how when she booked
friends happily shot a pilot they took
him to Las Vegas to celebrate yeah the
guy that wrote the pilot or the
showrunner on earth and producer set all
six them down and gave him all $5,000 or
$500 and said go spend this in the
casino this is going to be the last time
you gonna be able to walk through a
casino he said that he said that his
five allows me to you I want you to walk
through casino and spend this because
once this show airs you guys will never
be able to do this again Jesus that's
crazy and he I mean to know whether he
knew it or not I mean that that became
reality except for Ross you're like Ross
like you got a consider like what's his
name Schneider Schwimmer exactly
he started directing it's like but this
and those guys made so much money so
they're still making it really mad I'm
making money from talent they roll it
you know what a project can't even
imagine like why
ABCs crying cuz I know for a fact
NBC right now is putting that [ __ ]
friends reboot you know it I'm more
emotion yeah if you don't think that NBC
already got the calls up yeah you think
we put it back well your grace is back
woman grace is back any day now for
houses oh those chicks are getting a
million episode when the show broke up
that's they quote that's that quote gee
sorry they got together they got they
were smart they unionize himself utilize
themselves yeah those [ __ ] come
back at a rate of 750 in episode don't
like that the spoiler for the first 10
million you know what if they get
launched it doesn't matter cuz netflix
don't give a [ __ ]
Netflix will say friends come over into
100 episodes yeah we'll pay it eats Ichi
is a million a [ __ ] episode we don't
give a [ __ ] you're worth it to us yeah
we'll pay the Vig NBC what do you want
and we're gonna fly [ __ ] in overnight
yeah we're gonna fly [ __ ] your favorite
pizza from Chicago you want a little
deep-dish
it really is crazy we're TV is now
nothing is really knocking him dead guys
no like that's what you really have to
believe because of podcasting and all
this free content likely doesn't have
cable TV I don't either
really I got rid of it so you live off
the computer yeah Netflix and I chisel
under stone so you have Netflix and I
got Netflix Hulu Amazon HBO thing I got
eight times like I wasn't I was
scrolling I was spending 30 minutes
rolling through the cable and not
picking anything you know it's like 37
channels a c-span like in like 16 other
channels wrote you know Mexican football
like I couldn't even find something to
land on and like the other two were
Keeping Up with the Kardashians I was
like [ __ ] this [ __ ]
hazing how many nights I turned the TV
on
what the [ __ ] the [ __ ] go where's the
program we hug the channels and I'm
watching [ __ ] Lord honor
I love episode but I've seen three
thousand fifteen times Vincent D'Onofrio
no no I'm talking about the other ones
Oh dearest I'm up here are you talking
Jerry Oh Burt Orville Redenbacher Jerry
Orbach he donated his eyes did he know
anybody yeah like Jerry Orbach and the
best combination is Jerry's go back to
mr. big yeah then that feels great but
that's Xmas city bad it's content yeah
yeah see ya but I'm the same come on ten
that's not just race in it yeah I hate
that no but I'm a regular [ __ ] lawn
or the guy I like Benjamin Bratt that
was a nice good I like it with the black
guy no that's about the black guy that
came on and was a Jerry Orbach and then
you know he was so feisty then you know
came on for a while that was pretty
[ __ ] good cuz after once Jerry you're
like that I know who came on in a while
I was pretty [ __ ] christopher meloni
definitely that is Farina with the black
dude and he was good the first episode
though I was that is Verena carries so
much money his banana friend would carry
money with a rubber band a job that cops
crazy thought was a gangster he just had
that that's for me to replace Jerry you
are back it's running show about 120 30
years now but it's been over for like
six years now yes but they'll bring that
back you want it back me ah I know how
cable either button did you get a drink
of water cuz you looked so thirsty he's
got soda to water his lips look parched
I know [ __ ] such a pepperoni sell me
down the river you brought me the
meatball sandwich don't sell me down the
river nobody saw you though the real
you tell me I just randomly have a
meatball sandwich at work like that
looks something I do please I got my
rose butthole whether you had a [ __ ]
piece of pepperoni you had you had a
beautifully was it a piece of pepperoni
that [ __ ] still looked fresh and it was
right at your foot look if he would've
found that he put it in his pocket
let's kono it in that sort of way this
comes boogers god damn it do you really
did you just eat a booger no no my
fingers all right now just as disgusting
as a book that's terrible what we biting
your fingernails why are you nervous no
I'm from habit just this is what this
isn't listen you don't have much luck
let me Sirians let me touch can hold
your gets oh we have nice you don't have
a great hair you don't really soft hands
oh you've got great hands yeah they're
very soft there's a great hand so I cut
my fingernails before I Fendi Lee you
laugh that's God's work that's God's
work gotta do this these [ __ ]
come at you with like a coke nail and
they can slice your coochie skin up yeah
they come at you like a blanket Freddy
Krueger butcher
you can tell I'm married cuz now I don't
give a [ __ ] I don't finger banging them
I just stick my fingers in there yeah
just that whole hammer goes in there oh
my god
I got [ __ ] herring in here if I
figure somebody they'll [ __ ] die like
it's like putting an old what's that -
you have an old tampon in you know what
the culture shock that's the same
difference if I finger you with the
third the middle finger right now
between the things I think is the parks
I've been to the cocaine I've had on
wages hearts the parks better because
they're all filthy [ __ ] things the
planes I bring on if I figure you start
foaming from the mouth surprise you said
what's the thing of you leave the tampon
and you culture shock yeah whatever the
[ __ ] I can't toxic shock coaches shadow
[ __ ] no it's some type of shock I
know if I want the same toilet paper my
[ __ ] for two days
you have some type of [ __ ] shot or
something you reach back then you pull
that piece of toilet paper out it
scuffed up in your [ __ ]
Lee there's definitely toilet paper in
your [ __ ] all right now I'm doing
okay when I get bigger that I did that a
couple times that's why I travel with my
wipes cuz I like to keep my lady parts
fresh cuz I'm a lady
I'm a lady um rose water so when does
the week's door open lady every time
that the the laws change we have to
adjust so we were at the process of our
license going in and now we're just
crossing our fingers so hopefully we got
the location yeah you weren't in town
that weekend but our location is amazing
and so we're just waiting for you know
hopefully we have enough of an incentive
for the city to want to do business with
us how much how fast is it growing
doesn't crazy I mean you know the you're
more likely to get the license if you're
doing like a social equity exchange or
you're giving back to the community
because then it shows that you're gonna
actually have some sort of mutually
beneficial business as opposed to just
selling weed you know they're trying to
make it so that the the neighborhood
surrounding these dispensaries are
improving the neighborhood itself feel
like sponsor a baseball team or
something you know something like that
[ __ ] no but it's more involved it's like
actually you know and giving back to the
community and in doing actual things
that help them
that's nice again I mean you know it's I
just hope it happens soon me too you're
good you can crack your back
I live to Crown Derby today you went to
crack yo I saw a video of you in there
is it like when the first time you went
in does it hurt is it so cold it hurts
and did you want to get out no you
helmet
when I kid those drugs although she is
yeah I stop it cuz when you look
criminally should take chances
yeah I was fitted in Windows I was going
into attacking people through a rule
she's you know I was always doing
something I know after I Korea yeah I
forgot the prison yeah I did the cloudy
it was gonna in tell you I know not
knowing but once I got hooked on the
drugs it wasn't like that no more Tommy
was just second head yeah it was when I
really got hooked was 2010 I was doing
family 12 years 9 years 10 years it was
pretty good I was a regular at the store
you know so all those little thing has
helped yeah I just became a junkie after
that Wow so for all those years I didn't
really take chances
I didn't do nothing and it was weird
that let's be honest Rogen's a dear
friend of mine and [ __ ] but he's got
that Hollywood mentality from the time
right some people will lift some weights
no never I'm already doing kettlebells
yeah people start doing Calibos I'm
doing [ __ ] bats Elsa Tate I'm so
squatting with the ELCA tape there's
always something with those people but
one thing for sure
he has great motives like he has he does
everything he does do if you do it the
way he doesn't it's great yeah like we
have discussion about working out every
night
and now the work that I do is inspired
by what he taught and you're getting
results I was doing the right work out
yeah I was doing a little bit too much
he goes no you're doing too much
yeah do half of that and stretch yep
it'll be better for you yeah everything
changed yep and so yeah it's all about
crowd therapy I'm like this is another
one of those hot that's what I thought
too there's no one who's Hollywood thing
right like Pilates and they're like I
got I got really interested in recovery
yeah
I'm not fully learning I'm not
thirty-five right I'm 55 and yeah let's
be honest I locked my wife of my 40 left
listen [ __ ] left yeah and I
still get my wife stabbings and I still
like I don't know what kinds over I was
talking a little friend of mine
grammar school and I said something to
her and she goes do you still get hard
or something like she's crazy
yeah like I won't make you say that just
please I go on dates with guys all the
time you're right they can't they can't
dog no I get good hard-ons they're not
like when I was 14 I mean that's amazing
yeah yeah no no no you're not gonna have
that somebody was talking the other day
they're gonna my dick don't even work
the more friend of mine was yeah he's
two years older music Joey my dick Coco
my dick believe in her no more it goes
sometimes it dies and he was in my head
I'm banging the [ __ ] out of her and my
wife just looking at me like something
Louie and I'm banging it and he goes I
can't even feel it it's not hard now I
go my god you guys are scaring me that's
today I went outside to the kettlebells
whenever I feel my dick work and I do
kind of bow
you got a rough that area kettlebell
some cleans cleans some squats you get
that but tuba tuba Glen oh and you need
to protect your to e Glen whatever the
[ __ ] it is that's the gland you need to
spread everything out to the [ __ ] oh
my god say here yeah I love all these
technical terms that whole squad
deadlift got something to your body that
sets it off and your dick will be
working telling you this is life
violence guys I loved you Jitsu and I
love throwing kicks with Jesus like a
lot more title but I'll tell you what I
go in a yard I take a 35-pound
kettlebell I'll do some squats I thought
you're gonna say it took a 35-pound dump
I was like sure I'll do some [ __ ]
swings yeah
and then I'll do some cleans mm-hmm but
the strength is we take an 18 pound yeah
and we just push it three qualities on
the front turkey feel better yeah I
don't know what you're saying yeah yeah
you just do three sets of five on each
just gentle yeah you hope to kill
yourself no you don't have to kill
yourself at night you'll be sewing the
computer looking at my face muscle
for that helmet get along how did you
make sure your door is that one seed you
right chance man yeah my helmet is hard
right now the green man Alicia with the
two-prong crowd oh yeah it's a green
mentally she with the troops Ron crowd
is aim and never that bad time this is
part of me to movement this broadcast I
don't think this was shoutouts real
quick Kristi Bellis my girl Ryan be
silly wabbit big thumb Terry Adam and V
Aaron Oliver Roberts Fitz man 73 Ronnie
Martinez and my man tunnel snakes rule
don't forget the 13th and 14th of July
I'm at the South Point Casino in Las
Vegas
then the 26 in the 27th oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
Mormons sharpen your dicks and bury your
wife uncle Joey's coming to Salt Lake
City wise guys Friday and Saturday for
shows don't come fry to me Joey you
didn't tell me please get me oh man
thank you so much I have to I have to
leave you guys soon we'll take your time
but hurry up
just stay till 9:15 call them to attack
some dummy on your way um tell me you
going up halfway they'll line up begin a
barrier I'm hosting it's my show oh no I
mean you know just good for you you want
stage time you got to create your own
[ __ ] sometimes no good for you yeah
there's a lot of women that complain and
plan well it's it's this it's that it's
always something Thomas well he puts up
two women a night well then you know
what hang out when they do whatever they
do they put up Justin Martin down man
he's [ __ ] gay as [ __ ] don't give a
[ __ ] you think just among their
complaints no because people were just
born to complain
and you know when you get here if this
place don't give you a spot you got two
options you could cry about it you go
some windows box yeah if you just find a
place to sponsor spots a spot they're
not ready for you and you're not ready
for that now I assume that's the
situation goes somewhere else yeah if
you go somewhere else build it they'll
come to you [ __ ] Lee host on Saturday
I'm Mary probably day you took a little
[ __ ] Russian restaurant guess what
there's people showing up yeah I really
told me there's people actually showing
up now and Savin it was busy you'll see
thing here but the week before we have
like 25 30 beers and she said awesome
you know comedy is like anything else
you know everybody wants everybody wants
it to be easy Alissa they think of the
Bluebird a happier knock on your door no
it's awesome are you busy no one's ever
I got someone for his dates yeah his
people go get it you gotta put a smile
on your face and you don't want this
this business were in this company
business once you realize listen yeah
I wish I told you about the funny it's
not about the funny it's about
commitment yep your love for it and
showing people that you know how to have
a good time I'm like also speaking about
[ __ ] that you you've experienced oh not
just trying to be funny funny but just
talking about your [ __ ] you know what I
mean well because of the podcasts age
people are seeing what the real funk is
yeah would bring in the funk of whose
faith enough yep the podcast changed
everything it changed only Central
changed a lot of [ __ ] day again they
gave people's perspective oi hmm how
come these guys will never on this yeah
these guys are the ones that are [ __ ]
fun these are the guys that talk to me
these are guys that I relate to you know
so what this guy did a little time like
I always I'm very self-conscious about
doing time talk about it because I have
to yeah I have to let people know who
the [ __ ] you are yeah but deep down
inside I'm like [ __ ] you know when
people come up and take a picture with
me and they're like man thank you for
listening to the podcast I'm less
sitting like if this [ __ ] I knew
what I was doing for thing is wrong he
wouldn't know that even they don't even
know 25 years ago two days ago wouldn't
have his [ __ ] arm around
yeah my friend call means a hey Matt and
something happened I was walking I lost
a call I tried to call him back
and sometimes I'm working in the phone
call goes through but sometimes you just
they just go oh it dies it doesn't like
anything as much as you try not and I
usually call that dial oral Canyon I
usually talk to people as soon as I
start getting a little game I start
calling people I have full cost it you
never say I hope to get them off by the
time I get the the third light on the
dead zone or not they're like let me ask
you something I'm like wait there we go
and also you're going let me ask you
something back that time and there's
nothing anyway hello hello hello they're
like okay you don't hear nothing yeah
and then you don't get a phone call back
to you pass cold what's that the top law
and Mo Holland there's cold water Creek
by the time you get like the quarter
mile you get for yeah once you start no
swerving no nothing on the way down you
start to Ventura yeah yeah and then what
once you pass that one [ __ ] 90 mile
an hour race yeah yeah you're good to go
do you call anybody [ __ ] I'm on the
phone with Mo ici tongue over there and
[ __ ] after the conversation for Trump
to find out what happened with trumping
he'll say I wouldn't that be [ __ ] on
shop I'm gonna have any blow jobs Trump
in that [ __ ] little Korean guy got
last can you even oh my god never get a
singer they were eating out these
Singapore chicks they all splashing your
face Lee those [ __ ] did everything a
project does oh that's why they call
them Singapore sling that cocktail nut
that [ __ ] wallet a security Singapore
sling like I've had in my mouth when
held in my mouth God was a little bit I
used to have a girlfriend that would
spray me what's that called squirt and
at first I didn't know what it was there
was no anything I couldn't look at my
god but after a while I hate it there
I just learned I was finger hunt so she
squirt and I would open my mouth like a
[ __ ] like a savvy Labrador at the all
and I would love it when she said I
could feel it like I wish you were
sampler
no she was a
no she's from Sacramento okay she's from
truth oh when they squirt is
tremendously saya sure you see your
[ __ ] little horn and getting filled
and it just [ __ ] and it just doesn't
work you give it run away like a [ __ ] I
open up your mouth and take it like a
man like a homeless person in a fountain
holy [ __ ]
oh my god Wow Louise if it takes squirts
Lee what would you do not have the
awesome I'll take the squirt yeah no man
if it tasted fishy waters
well see what happened I don't know what
thanks like a mole sieve of colleague
fish eyeballs bright lit up with sugar I
think my friend issued opposed it tastes
like that yes sir that's the bone the
stronger the more poignant the baby
every time when a woman has a baby tonic
state well woman has a baby she has
something after word comes up yes after
birth when you plan for the new yard
sure some people cook it don't pay they
cook they chop it up with Parmesan
[ __ ] peppers you know nobody's a lady
to be nuts I'm late cuz Joey was giving
me a placenta you won't get the flu for
22 [ __ ] years you missed it I'll take
us like sucking 18 drinks and thinking
this drink of the sperm it's a you if
it's the Fountain of Youth I'll just
take that koala my god no but the scent
is real I mean they make products out of
placenta it's crazy
human black-market placenta put that in
my [ __ ] like Christmas stocking a
real some black-market placenta no this
are like a nice lotion just like beliefs
what about what you said about squirt
and he started sweating no I like
squirting this is this poor percent f3
over the edge okay some Lila center with
some what's Adele a piece of [ __ ] I
don't roll the CD
you won't even know two words just a
woman it's just a woman just tell you
something you look prettier than ever
your skin looks beautiful oh yeah but
happy your love oh sorry you don't have
enough time I don't want you to get the
show late I wish I could hear all night
the way you do me down the [ __ ] hell I
wish I could stay here all night long I
love you thank you for coming love you
too you always have an open the door
don't be a stranger
come on whatever the [ __ ] you want I
appreciate you I appreciate you too yeah
I've had it to Disneyland with my [ __ ]
good luck with that ticket god damn
those hot dogs are like $37 you just
you're gonna [ __ ] eat you know what I
work on all year yeah I almost not
called
I think you need to put that on a
t-shirt FC 55 yeah everything I do that
was so she don't end up like I did if
something happens yeah I get it
something happens I don't my wife in
good shape yeah so you know please get
out of here
mm-hmm that's it
yeah take care yourself mm-hmm you gotta
drink water you got a drink water a lot
of [ __ ] you really do micheladas and
water yeah no I saw you drinking that
michelada you ever drink one that you
will stop at nothing badgering Hitler no
el compadre that's what I got the
micheladas around point oh I'm gonna go
check them out get the one with the
Mitchell Island the seafood in it what
so you drink the meat you you drink in
that's got shrimp and [ __ ] scallops a
little bacon with pieces of avocado and
that [ __ ] this is el compadre
16 apiece you get two of those and you
click swells up like [ __ ] Harvey
Weinstein's head that's what it looks
like
let's wells like Harvey Weinstein's I
wish to go from them you show it the
other men and they had crumble look at
this cliff face it looks like oh my god
probably this tooth that you know the
same for you
are you nuts or what yeah jessimae
Peluso ways in general yeah [ __ ]
that's a tampon when you leave it in
there for a few and [ __ ] you always
give me a call
next thing I string those up that monkey
know you've got to keep the string out
if you don't you can't lose the string
that's when you forget it is there this
chicken I took the string of the [ __ ]
that was the game we play oh my god
we're stringing you a little monkey and
I'll suck it out oh you've never played
that game me know yeah that's at one
time I did like I [ __ ] it out I hate all
that [ __ ] what I do like is I give it to
you in the butt bang in the butt and
then it shoots out the tampon shoes out
I take it and I work it like a [ __ ]
swallow for salami like a little dignity
and it's worth little blood like I'm
stabbing it Jesus like it's like where
do we go from here right before the
pussy's gonna die it settle as a breath
of fresh air I love you [ __ ]
don't forget the 7th I don't even know
7:13 14th the South Point and at the end
of the month in July wiseguys this Salt
Lake City
I want to thank jessimae Peluso one more
time for coming on my famous
[ __ ] but most of all I want to
thank you [ __ ] yo Fuji
well is it Fuji sports.com they got the
Mac Daddy DS the [ __ ] everything in
the world of martial arts they been
around since Godzilla go to Fuji
sports.com right now impress in church
boom 10% off delivered right to your
[ __ ] crib you know I'm saying and you
helped out the podcast a hard number to
listen when it comes to supplements and
it's the only way I roll whether it's
the Alpha brain the shroom tech the new
protein powder whatever the [ __ ] it's
called they got a new on it
six its six-week course you pay for it
you do jumping jacks um body weight
exercising your [ __ ] house
it changes your [ __ ] world you
understand me it's on its six something
else in the mind of Aubrey and that's it
gonna come right now impress in church
boom and don't forget to get the bacon
elk sausage go change your whole [ __ ]
life go honey calm right now impress in
church boom and there you go get 10% off
the Liberty house talk to me Jessamine
that sounds delicious some bacon elk
sausage that's probably Joe Rogan's
breakfast
yeah what the [ __ ] you doing with that
thing you might have killed that oh he's
easy
lked ain't every morning yeah you can
find me at Jesse Wacom check me out I
got my sharp tongue podcast my hilarious
podcast and I am I feel very happy that
you had me back yes whatever you want
you check in on me that means a lot I
always gotta check in on my sisters and
brothers in the comedy world who give a
[ __ ] about me I love you thank you guys
very much for coming on to that
listening and I want to thank the
[ __ ]
you got your shout outs that's it
[ __ ] see you Father's Day I
love your [ __ ] stay black kick
that mule Lee